merci les mecs avoir mené en histoire
mais c'est avant une destination
agréable détendre récompensés
[Musique]
à
doyon
[Musique]
vraiment bien
tu là
[Musique]
nous il ya 80 100 degrés nickel faire
des pâtes le principe des geysers c'est
qu'en fait il ya un amas de pression
pendant plusieurs minutes et leur coût
caméra mouillé
c'est parti pour une session automobile
tout terrain
[Musique]
oman
non
là bas ok c'est par la main ici est de
cascades d'eau qui sont très connus
d'abord il ya celle ci puis à celle ci
est encore plus sauvage et farouche que
les chutes du niagara faut aimer c'est
un style heugas cateau et mais moi
j'aime beaucoup
ici il ya une légende et ça c'est très
sérieux il paraît qu'il ya des trolls
qui habitent les montagnes qui sortent
depuis des siècles et des siècles la
nuit pour venir marquer leur territoire
on endette petit tas de cailloux comme
celui-ci et faire peur aux enfants
la légende raconte également que les
plaques de verglas retrouver comme celui
ci serait de lure in de troll congelés
pendant la nuit qu'il faut les chais
pour soigner les maladies
depuis quelques années le prix du
mobilier a complètement chuté ici donc
c'est intéressant d'investir
par exemple dans un mètre carré c'est
plus flou du monde des entendants
vêtements de ski sous la pluie attendant
d'autres ont peiné à poil dehors dans un
lagon bleu gipat clips ou des skis
[Musique]
à le blue lagoon c'est maintenant
terminé on a une poule homogène et riche
en oligo éléments c'est d'obtenir la
boule la plus parfaite du monde
problème ils ont conçu les camps pour
une tortue ninja quoi les banques
dépassent pas pour les aimants sa [ __ ]
voulait pas les tortues merde si peu
intello mon accoutrement est plutôt
improbable par rapport à la situation
des lieux rend fou des raisons
[Musique]
et
à ce jour la culture du monde s'est
infiltrée par le volcan pop la musique
ah ok je sais ce que ressentait le court
que tout jeu c'est waou
le rayon jaloux est ce que savait qu'ici
en islande au pays des vikings
ils sont tellement peu nombreux environ
300000 habitants que les jeunes couples
sont obligés de vérifier sur un site
internet pour voir s'ils n'ont pas un
lien de parenté
ça s'appelle island et kabok parce que
sinon ils feraient des bébés si tu vois
un peu chelou
je vais voir s'il ya pas quelqu'un à ma
famille en islande
[Musique]
on part à tokyo semaine prochaine à
bientôt
[Musique]